>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
POSSIBLE THAT NO SINGLE PERSON
PHYSICALLY EMBODIES THE SPIRIT
OF CORRUPTION IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., MORE PERFECTLY
THAN THE FORMER ACTING DIRECTOR
OF THE FBI.
IN 2016, IN THE EARLY DAYS OF
THE PRESIDENTS ADMINISTRATION,
HE USED HIS POWER WHICH WAS
CONSIDERABLE AT THE STOKE A
WITCH HUNT RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
HOLDING A POSITION OF PUBLIC
TRUST FOUND PUBLIC TRUST.
HE LEAKED SENSITIVE INFORMATION
TO NEWS MEDIA FOR POLITICAL GAI
GAIN.
HE WAS CAUGHT DOING THIS.
HE WAS CAUGHT, HE PLAY THE
VICTIM.
HE TRIED TO AVOID THE
CONSEQUENCES AND THEN BECAUSE
THE WORLD IS NOT ALWAYS FAIR, HE
WALKED RIGHT INTO A CUSHY MEDIA
GIG OVER AT CNN.
A COMPANY THAT HAS LITERALLY NO
SCRUPLES.
NOW, THINGS HAVE CHANGED.
IF WE HAVE REASONS THAN I TO